aim to to San Salvador which is the name
Columbus gave to the island as if to
settle the argument I in the book I use
what the Indians call it go on a honey
there's no problem with it then wherever
guano honey was he sailed among among
the lower Bermudez then he went off and
he began sailing along Cuba which was to
be the richest of the islands that he
was to see but he didn't immediately
realize that and keep in mind he's still
exploring now he's keenly looking for
gold at this point they're trying
they're trying to follow the trail of
goal that they see the Indians wearing
they had reasonably good meetings there
they found that the Cuban of Tino's were
a bit more advanced than the ones on the
smaller islands their houses were a
little better their clothes were a
little more elaborate if you can call a
breechcloth
even on the woman elaborate they had
slightly better weapons and their art
apparently was just a bit more
sophisticated and what you saw in the
smaller islands he soon soon went on to
to Hispaniola
now that's Haiti in the Dominican
Republic and that's where they began
finding gold and that's where this story
starts getting a little ugly as you can
imagine bring bring bring bring money
and women into the lives of men and you
have conflict and the evil begins
flaring up but nevertheless things
compared to what would happen later went
pretty well until it was about time to
begin heading home on Christmas Eve in
what is now the north coast of Haiti
Columbus was very tired he stood watch
after watch while their other man's
standing watch he got very little sleep
when there was exploring and that's one
of the ways apparently he ruined his
health he finally had to give in and he
turned he turned the watch over to
another man who was tired who turned it
over to another man who turned it over
to a common seaman to steer the santa
maria and it was a quiet easy night
there was just a slight drift and on
this Christmas Eve Santa Maria drifted
in and drifted in till fine as she got
onto a reef and got caught and couldn't
get off and the waves lifted her up and
down up and down on top of that reef
until it just broke her hull open
and to this day whatever's left of the
Santa Maria is down there on that north
coast of Haiti what Columbus thought
well this is it we were in deep trouble
now because one of one of his one of the
three ships the painter had gone off on
another expedition of its own violating
his orders but who came to his rescue a
Cacique that's that's a tie no one word
that Cacique name wanna get gone to
Kagari I've never heard these names
pronounced so if the soul if his soul is
here I beg his forgiveness and
butchering his name came forward and and
helped Columbus as best he could
he told Columbus after a couple of days
of assisting assisting the Spaniards to
try to salvage what they could off of
the Santa Maria that if he would come
back that is if Columbus would come back
and visit he would have an a statue a
life-size statue made of Columbus
entirely in gold or there's no in the
world he could have done that but it was
a promise that that was a really a good
one to make to to European the point
here is that is that the Indian Cacique
showed great great generosity and as a
result what happened is that Columbus
decided to build a fort there and leave
part of the crew behind because he
couldn't take all the men on on the one
ship he had at that time the Nene ax so
he would leave half of the men there
they took some of the Timbers apparently
of the of the Santa Maria and and with
the help mostly with Indian labor built
a fort which they called La Navidad the
nativity keep in mind this was right
around Christmas the plan was they would
come back with within the year and
relieve that fort well he sailed off and
came across somewhat bye-bye lock
Columbian Columbus had a great deal of
luck more of it good than bad this was
one of the lucky things he happened to
cross the path of the Pinta and the the
two captains made up and so they had two
ships to return instead of just one but
what happened is as they got near the
the eastern Atlantic they got into
terrible tempest on two or three times
and I won't tell you all the stories of
what happened during these tempest it's
really I think a fascinating part of
this tale
but somehow they managed to survive
those those tempest when Columbus
returned to Spain in 1493 after 96 days
just 96 days in the in the new world
word had gone ahead about what he had
done and he was the hero and the
procession from from the seaport up to
the court was was it was a great moment
for him never would it be better in his
life that's when it all came together
for him and he reaped the the fame that
he really did desire this was a man who
was not content at least at that point
in its life on modesty he later would
take to wearing Franciscan robes perhaps
his penance for his pride we were not
sure well the second voyage which lasted
from 1493 to 1496 two and a half years
got underway only months after he got
back the goal this time was to establish
a trading colony not a colony of
settlement exactly of the kind say that
the English were attempting to do in
this country later this was this was
just to be a trading colony to bring to
bring primarily gold and silver and
pearls out of out of this new land
it consisted of 17 ships and more than a
thousand men I keep in mind his I didn't
tell his but his first his first crew
was was about 90 men and three ships he
headed to a Dominica and landed there
which is a little farther south in the
Caribbean from where he was and then he
began sailing up the curve of islands
there and until he came to st. Croix
which as you know is today American
territory that's that's the only time he
ever set foot in anything we might say
is America the Indians on on on st.
Croix were not tigh knows they work
Arabs and as a great deal debate about
the degree of cannibalism that the
carobs practiced primarily upon tyne
owes I think that yes they did they did
practice cannibalism the people now who
try to deny that it's not convincing to
me certainly the calves were much more
warlike than the Thai nose even though
they're related people's much more
aggressive
and immediately trouble started the
Spanish where it went we're in one one
one conflict after the other after one
particular nasty encounter
it's very bloody and described in detail
by a couple of different people this
happened I want to read you this because
it's one of the most remarkable accounts
I know of the conquest of the Americas
it's it it comes from a very long letter
and don't picture a letter in a couple
pages this is essentially a small
pamphlet which was published not long
after the second voyage ended written by
a childhood friend of Christopher
Columbus an Italian named him Michael de
kunio-kun a Oh to the sea and in this
letter he talks about the battle at the
head of the Caribes and capturing some
of the Caribes Columbus made it a
practice whenever he met a new tribe of
impressing as you would impress a seaman
capturing a local tribe to serve as a
guide and also to service translators he
did take about a half a dozen Indians
back that first time so they might learn
Spanish and and and come back and work
as translators so he had some he had
some Caribes aboard this is what
Canaille writes in italian of course
while i was in the boat i captured a
very beautiful carob woman whom the Lord
Admiral Columbus gave to me and with
whom having taken her into my cabin she
being naked according to custom I
conceived desire to take pleasure I
wanted to put my desire into execution
but she did not want it and treated me
with finger nails in such a manner that
I wished I had never begun but seeing
that to tell you the end of it all I
took a rope and thrashed her well for
which she raised such unheard of screams
that you would not have believed your
ears finally we came to an agreement in
such manner that I can tell you that she
seemed to have been brought up in a
school of harlots
I don't know of any account written by
anybody who went into the new world that
is so frank in describing rape in both
its terms of sexual intercourse and rape
in in terms of a pillaging of society
that is more symbolic than that
particular act now what I want to say if
you read Canelo's letter otherwise he
comes across as a very reasonable decent
fellow the kind of person you wouldn't
mind sitting down and having a martini
with was the exception this one very
frank account clearly he writes us
without shame at all and keep in mind it
was Columbus that gave him the woman the
Columbus went on to Lana Lana Navidad to
see how the fort was was getting along
they get they came in after dark and
they sent so they put some torches up
trying to signal the fort no word no
response the next morning at that
sunrise they looked over there and the
fort was gone they went ashore in the
longboats and found out that had been
burned they searched up and down they
found the anchor of the Santa Maria they
found they found numerous decomposing
bodies only somewhat recently
decomposing what they found out is well
they didn't find out that this came out
later that that the Spanish men who had
had gone from sailors to soldiers so to
speak and occupying that fort simply
didn't behave very well and they began
making raids into the up country and
they were stealing women they were
stealing children to use his servants
they were stealing whatever goal they
had they they had no food of their own
so they had they had to either steal
food or try to barter for it they were
pillaging the land in short and they
came across one Thai knowwho Cacique who
said I'm not going to tolerate this and
very wisely rather than taking the the
Spanish on head first he he picked them
off a few at a time one here one there
until finally he got their numbers down
there only about 40 of them he got their
numbers down to such an extent that that
the Indians at night could go and attack
the fort and kill the rest of the
Spaniards and
burned burned la navidad who came to
Columbus's aid the friendly Cacique once
again who was apparently honestly
claimed that he had tried to defend a
for his best he could but he was no
match for this
this is upland chief who eventually
drowned at sea on a Spanish ship
well Columbus realized that that was not
a regulation location for a fort anyway
so they they established new one which
he called La Isabella that was not a
very good location either but it served
for a while they moved inland and
established another fort called Santo
Tomas perhaps because Columbus was
making mark of people who had doubted
him and his enterprise Santo Tomas was a
better location they built some other
smaller forts this is in Haiti and the
Dominican Republic what you see is that
Columbus is no longer functioning as an
explorer now he is functioning as a
conquistador and I don't know what you
were taught as a child but I was
certainly never taught that that
Columbus was a conquistador but when you
consider much of what he did his will
become clear as I go on here
he was the first conquistador at that
point he does several things one he
permits he permits other men to to
engage in robbery kidnapping rapes
punishments they go after the Indians
with Spanish war dogs the kind of dogs
that the Indians had were barkless dogs
and they were kept not as defense the
Indians kept them to eat so they were
they were not dogs that she would would
be useful in a battle but the Spanish
war dogs were really terrifying there
are figures in there that one war dog
was was equivalent to about about 20
Indian fighters this this is conquest
this is depopulating an island now what
we haven't even brought up the issue of
disease that that's something beyond I'm
not sure we can blame that on Columbus
but certainly as commander of these
things these other things he does bear
responsibility
but to my mind that the most horrifying
find horrifying thing of all is that he
he captured almost a thousand Thainess
and brought them down to to La Bella and
they picked off the 500 best men women
and children and they sent those they
put them on ships and keep in mind for
17 ships so he sent several ships back
to the slave market in Seville anybody
who any the Spaniards who were still
there and wanted to take some of the
rest of the Indians were free to choose
among themselves to take what was left
and those who were not chosen I must be
talking now about people who were who
were disabled in some way infirm perhaps
very homely I don't know what it might
be those people were permitted to run
for the hills and they survived for a
while
Columbus began at this time also
extorting gold from the Indians they
were forced to work to produce a certain
amount of gold each month and if they
fail to produce that that that amount of
gold the punishment could be severing of
ears or noses our hands it the penalties
were very severe for not coming in with
enough gold the problem was gold was
extremely hard to find on this Caribbean
island it was there but you had to work
hard to get very much of it so they what
the Indians first gave up all of their
their family jewels you might say and
once those were gone then they were out
scratching and digging in the earth
trying to come up with enough gold and
eventually they just couldn't meet the
quota Columbus had to modify some of
that well he realized he needed to start
a better town than what he had so he
sent his brother off was with him he had
two brothers he son off his middle
brother - found what eventually became
Santo Domingo in the Dominican Republic
the oldest city in the Western
Hemisphere he went off in the ship to
explore that whenever Columbus was on
land he really was not only not a
particularly good human being he was not
a good commander always almost all his
problems at least the most serious
problems occurred while he was on land
when he was at sea he did much better he
went off it went off
leaving the island in the hands of some
of these these truly grisly characters
things got even worse while he was gone
when he came back he was ready to head
for home two and a half years later now
and he had a rough time getting home
because he missed that a landok gyre and
by the time that they pulled into into
Spain after this hard voyage the ships
were just beat all to hell and people
knew who he was then they came and they
looked at they looked at these beat-up
ships with it with the sails ragged and
broken and and leaking and they looked
at the sick man aboard aboard the ship
this the sick sailors they looked at the
dying Indians and it became very hard
for Columbus to get other people to to
go with him after that point
nevertheless the third voyage did come
about two lasted from 1498 to 1500 the
purpose of this one was primarily to to
assist the new colonies to help them
help them along and also to explore to
the south of the Caribbean for a rumored
large continent line to the south this
was the first voyage to include women
now it also included minor criminals I
I'm not sure that there were any
murderers in there but people who are in
prison for debt or people who were there
for as pickpockets certainly prostitutes
any number of crimes that would be
considered lesser crimes those people
could go to the new world and if they
survived which was a good question if
they survived and they came back to
Spain they they had a certain amount of
money for them and they received amnesty
so this these ships were really not the
kind of people you'd want to take a
cruise with there were seven ships they
went to Trinidad and met up with some
carobs there but the curve is that came
out to the ships to a certain a certain
distance stopped in their dugout canoes
a dugout canoe is a tree that's been
hollowed out it's not a canoe of the
birch bark that we associate say with
northeastern United States they came out
in their dugouts but they stopped and
Columbus wanted to
the Morrie goal was where the pearls or
he wanted to talk to them he maybe
wanted to get another interpreter so he
thought well maybe I can lure them here
so he had a bunch of the men come up on
deck with chamber pots and and bang
their shiny things anything shiny they
banged in the clanked and they shined
these pots around that didn't seem to
work so he brought out a Fife and drum
corps of some sort that he had with him
and they began moving around in
formation and the and the Indians in the
canoes interpreted this as a war dance
so they they launched arrows at this
but then strangely enough they stopped
the launch of arrows and and Columbus at
this time did not retaliate usually he
would retaliate but did not retaliate
this time so the the carobs came on and
came up to the boats and one very bold
Christian jumped down into one of the
one of the dugouts and gave somebody a
trinket or something so their little
trading started but nothing serious
and those people never came back the
next day so Columbus went on and ended
up along the coast of Venezuela about
that time he had a serious eye infection
he couldn't see he just didn't feel well
so he stayed aboard most of the time
during this this sailing round of
Venezuela as a result he wanted to claim
any land that he saw for for Spain so he
would he would send envoy's a shore as a
result of doing this Columbus never set
foot in South America his men did but he
didn't as he moved along he noticed that
that the the Orinoco River with his with
us I don't how many miles that River has
it's got to be hundreds you notice all
this water coming in and he noticed how
long the shoreline was going he didn't
didn't didn't see any endurance this
apparently wasn't an island and so he
decided this is an unknown continent and
he called it another world not a new
world but in other world and he sailed
along and seen more and more yes that's
what this has to be but this is another
one of the great Columbian mysteries he
didn't stop it didn't stop again and get
off and go into this he did decide
however that having read his ancient
sources this apparently was the Garden
of Eden and I don't know what kind of
sailor you would be but if I were
sailing and I thought that's the Garden
of Eden I would be in here I mean if if
if she's in there I want can you see the
statue over here if she's in there lady
Eve then I would like to at least take a
look I want to see those apples I want
to see that tree he went on in his
defense we might say that he did know
that that that his brother in the in the
nude town of Santa Domingo needed
supplies and help so he was he wasn't
moving along to get there when he
arrived he found out that the conditions
were just horrible strife was rampant
the Spanish were fighting among
themselves and they were taking it out
on the Indians they were well into their
into their campaign of decimating the
tyne was on the island disease was
starting to affect both both cultures it
was it was just a wretched place to be
Columbus got involved in this and he did
what he could to try to rectify it but
it just he couldn't do much he was he
was not that kind of a leader and what
he finally did was become tyrannical at
the end and maybe to tear if he'd been
triangle at the front end of things that
might have worked but it's too late and
what happened Spain sent some executives
over to check on him
those people at least in his eyes became
his enemies and they dealt with it with
the the people who are in authority then
and this is the trip that you may have
heard about this is the trip in which
Columbus went back to Spain and chains
both of his brothers went with him the
the captain of the ship said to Columbus
I'll be happy to take once words say
I'll take these chains off of you and
Columbus you could play the martyr role
pretty well said no only the Queen can
remove these chains I'll keep them on
and so for this rather long trip home he
traveled in Chains and I find
considerable iron here in that in a way
he was going back as the slave in the
same way that he had sent so many
Indians already at that point back to
Spain as slaves well when he got back he
defend himself in court as did his two
brothers they did a good job and
the Queen and King restored some of
their some of their perquisite s-- and
he was doing alright again clearly
though each time that this would happen
he would become more and more
disaffected with certainly with royalty
with with bureaucracies if not with
humankind itself but he put together the
fourth voyage this one he called the
high voyage this was this was the one
that was really to bring things in it
took some time to set it up he had a
great many obstacles the main thing that
he was running up against is it that
that people didn't want to travel with
him anymore he had gotten a reputation
as a bad luck man what he did find was
that teenagers would go
I mean teenagers will do anything right
so he got a lot of teenagers on this
trip including his his son Ferdinand his
youngest son Ferdinand has left us some
accounts of the fourth voyage is one of
the very rich accounts of the fourth
voyage the goal of this one was to
explore in the Western Caribbean
primarily with the idea of trying to
find the alleged that presumed the
mythical straight to the Indian Ocean
once once he found that straight and
could enter the Indian Ocean he was on
his way to China he knew that that was
the key thing
Queen Isabella made it clear to him
there was to be no slaving on this
voyage thanks thank heavens that she did
it she'd been opposed to it all along
but finally she became up clearly with
that edict he he sailed again to Senator
Mingo because that was the headquarters
of Spain now in the new world as he
arrived the old the old sea-dog that he
was he knew what Caribbean hurricane was
like he could he could smell it he could
feel it he knew the air he could look at
the clouds
he knew the hurricane was coming and he
told the governor of the island then a
man named nicolas de ovando ovando
remember that name the Wando that
hurricane was coming and you should get
the ships into protection ovando laughed
at him and said what is the old man know
the old man has now become a soothsayer
and the governor of ando sent off thirty
ships back to spain with with some of
the loot including at the order of the
royal court the worst leaky a ship
Columbus's gold on it clear the idea was
this ship is never going to make it so
Columbus was going to lose his gold
well those thirty ships caught the
tornado as Columbus said they would
Columbus went the other way and found a
safe place to type and all that with his
four ships all they got rocked around a
great deal they survived only a couple
of the ships of the thirty managed to
survive another piece of Columbian luck
one of the ships that did survive was
the one with his gold on it and it got
back to Spain and that money remained
his he got away with he'd beaten ovando
he didn't beat ov on to very often but
he did then he took his four ships he
knew that he wasn't wanted in Senator
Mingo so he went on west to find a
strait and he headed toward Honduras of
the great lost cities they were lost
even in the great lost cities that that
are in the Yucatan and in the and the
jungles of Belize and Honduras and
Guatemala he never heard anything about
those the Indians often gave him very
accurate directions and sailing
distances judged based upon their their
dugouts but they never mentioned they
never mentioned these lost cities so
whether they were hiding them or didn't
know I I have no idea but a Columbus
missed all of that and all of all the
wealth that went with those incredible
semi lost civilizations the first
Indians that he met on the Honduran
islands as he always did he brought out
the gold and the silver and the pearls
and showed them to them and with again
the language had changed and they were
having to deal with signs and and and
really poor communication that he wanted
to know where he could find these or the
Indians didn't know but they wanted to
trade for the gold the silver in the
pearls and commerce said no no no we we
want them though we don't have anything
so he went on moving along the the the
east side of Central America what he
found is that the Indians there invited
their medium of exchange was the cocoa
bean that was extremely valuable to them
Columbus saw no no value in that
whatsoever he had already in the first
voyage he had encountered this this weed
that that the that the tie nose would
roll up and put up their nose
and inhale and blow out and pass around
he's found no value in that either of
the crops that Columbus missed and the
old and silver that that Spain would
take out of the new world of course was
tremendous but when you consider the
longer than the long run they're really
valuable things to come out of there
were not so much gold and silver it was
things like tobacco it was it was
chocolate cocoa Columbus mis missed all
of that although he encountered it there
they even used the word cigar comes as
tying another cigar Oh another tie know
one word I guess though if you're
putting cigars up your nose that might
not be quite as alluring as other ways
you can smoke it he turns south and on
the 14th of August 1502 what just about
a month ago in 500 years he at last
finally set his foot on the continent of
North America if you want to call
Central America a separate continent you
may I think it's part of North America
but at least he got on the Continental
mass one of them that's the that's
that's the first and only time he never
reached North America proper what we
consider North America properly or South
America's I've said he thought he was on
more Islands out off the coast of China
he still had no idea where he was now
keep in mind this is one of the finest
navigators of the day he could out
navigate anybody he just didn't aware he
was otherwise in a larger scheme of
things he could get point to point but
where that was in the terms of the whole
globe that's he just couldn't shake
these these predispositions that he had
he was a man of deductive logic and if
you believe in deductive logic you end
up often with with lots of problems he
was not a man who used inductive
thinking he got into lots of bad weather
as he sailed down and just tore the
ships apart that the weather was so bad
they couldn't pull the ships ashore as
they needed to do every so often Kareem
the ships and roll them over on their
side and scrape scrape the barnacles and
other things off and and treat them with
pitch and tar to keep the worms out they
just couldn't do that so the weather
beat the devil out of them and then they
begin having some trouble with with the
Indians here and there
clearly dissatisfaction among the crew
began to grow it was just a wretched
trip perhaps the worst of all of his
four voyage is that that element of it
he got into one situation that there was
some strife but then it seemed it seemed
Li kind of smooth out in the next
morning after some struggles the cacique
wanting to smooth ways diplomat
diplomatically did that apparently what
was common among his culture and he sent
two girls out to the ship these are
offerings now when I say girls I mean
girls one was eight years old the other
was 14 now you can imagine these men at
sea for this time under great
deprivation the incredible danger these
two children were in but Columbus's son
was along Ferdinand and Columbus did not
apparently we have this from Ferdinand
so you have to take that with a bit of
solvers Columbus protected these girls
he closed them put cheap jewels on them
trinkets and sent them back to the chief
of what he assumed was the right thing
to do now this is very rare for Columbus
to do anything like this he did it a few
other times the chief was insulted
because that was not the proper use of
these children so sometimes even when he
wanted to do what we would consider
today the ethical moral thing it would
backfire on him but certainly his son at
least if we can believe the story his
son saw his father behaved admirably he
got down as far as Panama and at that
point he could begin to see the great
Cordillera there the mountains and he
began realized and there's no there
going to be no straight through those
mountains
this whole Strait must be a myth I would
have thought at this point his heart
would been broken he would have been
depressed but that isn't what you see
reading reading between things perhaps
because about that time they came across
a tribe of Indians known as the guianese
the grammys had gold in a fair amount of
it so the attention of the voyage the
point suddenly goes to the gold and
exploration seems to fall away again
with the gold present the skirmishes
became more and more severe the storms
continued
they were just being eaten alive by the
ship worms the Trados the food because
of all of the moisture humidity in the
rain the food that the Mariners were
eating was going bad many of them took
to eating their their their gruel at
night because they didn't want to see
the maggots that they had to eat to eat
to eat in daylight was to see this and
probably lose your lose your lunch
literally things getting more and more
tense while Columbus decided to turn
back and he starts heading back up the
coast of Central America and he anchored
in Lamone Bay which is in Panama now if
you've ever taken a cruise and gone
through the Panama Canal you know that's
the eastern end of the Panama Canal
he was anchored at the eastern end the
Panama Canal and the Indians told him
Bigwater over over these mountains lots
of water over there he was less than 50
miles from the Pacific Ocean this is
what he had come to find he didn't know
it was Pacific Ocean he thought it was
the Indian Ocean but that's what he'd
come to find and what does he do
so they came up to the northern coast of
Jamaica and it got close to shore and
and took everything they could they
could offload from the ships that got
rid of all the stone ballast anything
they could raft ashore it made the ships
as light as they could and then on on an
incoming tide they let the ships in
random as far as they could up onto a
reef not far off the shore right
together so that the two ships were were
almost touching each other their hulls
almost touching each other and Columbus
turned that into kind of a fortification
at the time having no idea how long he
would have to live on those two ships
the he had not had good receptions in
Jamaica before from the Thai nose there
they were not the most tractable
friendly of the Thai nose that he had
met but he knew better how to deal with
him now so things went pretty well he
also knew why should say this first
fortunately probably for both the
Christians and the Indians there wasn't
any gold around there so that took that
element of conflict away but there were
there were women wearing a little more
than what our lady eve over here is
wearing and keep in mind I told you
these were teenagers who now probably
were coming up into 18 19 20 years of
age Columbus knew this this was a was a
lit fuse so in a way that I can't
imagine this working given how small
these ships were nobody could could go
ashore without permission so he
controlled how many how many men could
be on liberty at any one time and that
for some way apparently worked for a
while the Spanish had come equipped on
this particular voyage without a ship
right without any tools to make or
repair ships and they had no knowledge
anybody was knowledge or the tools to
practice agriculture so they were
stranded they were marooned what they
had to do was to begin trading with with
the Thai nose for food Columbus realized
immediately that it's going to take only
so long before the Indians get all Hawk
bells and the little glass beads that
they want then what do we do for food
it's going to be a problem well maybe
we'll be rescued before that happens it
was 500 miles more or less to Santa
Domingo
let me read you one one statement here
which I find revealing Columbus was at
the look probably at the lowest point in
his life here you can well imagine that
everybody there figured this is probably
the end of it for us certainly his hopes
had been dashed everything he had
thought it hoped to find on this voyage
had failed he was not going to find that
the Strait to the Indian Ocean and he
was ill when he wrote this but he wrote
he wrote a letter to the king and queen
that he hoped one day they would see he
says I have no hair upon me that is not
white and my body is infirm and
exhausted all that was left to me into
my brother's has been taken away and
sold even to the cloak that I wore to my
great dishonor I believe this was not
done by your Royal Command
but the restitution of my honor and
losses and the punishment of those who
have inflicted them of those who
plundered me of my pearls and who have
disparaged my Admirals privileges will
redound to the honour of your royal
dignity dignity if you will enact it
hitherto I have wept for others now have
pity upon me heaven and wait for me
earth isolated in this pain infirm daily
expecting death surrounded by a million
savages full of cruelty how neglected
will be this soul if hear it part from
the body weep for me whoever has carroty
truth and justice to my mind an utterly
incredible statement it was by the
generosity of the Indians that he had
survived during all of these years yes
he had met with warfare when when he had
taken things that were not his but to
speak of savages full of cruelty he had
forgotten his great friend who had saved
tried to save him when the santamaría
broke out many other times the Indians
bringing them food
he had a man aboard named Diego Mendez
who at this point began saving Columbus
time and time again this is the kind of
ship mate that if one is captain you
really want to have Diego Mendez that
took a suit of armor and went off into
the bush and traded for a dugout canoe
from the Thai nose he came back and he
modified it so that he could sail it
with what I know helped across the miles
of between Jamaica and and the Dominican
Republic and tried to alert them in
senator Mingo that what was going on the
first try he failed to make it he had to
come back
he lost the canoe not to be stopped he
found another canoe and took off a
second time it took them four days but
they finally did reach reach the island
of Haiti Hispaniola on the Haitian end
of things and this was a piece of bad
Colombian luck because where is it that
that Mendez and and his men pile up
right at the end of the island where
ovando happened to be conducting a
punishing expedition against the Indians
for standing up for themselves so he
puts himself into Columbus's greatest
adversary an enemy governor de ovando
well ovando thought this is perfect now
I know where Columbus is he's stranded
he's not going to survive their disease
or the Indians are elements something's
going to get him so he he told Mendez
Walt I'll help you but let's see what
happens well it took months and months
and months and he's effectively stranded
Mendez on that island Mendez could get
no word to Columbus that he had reached
reached civilizations such as it was
then detentions up on Jamaica among the
men had reached the breaking point and
they split almost exactly into almost
evenly and two into two forces the
mutineers led by a couple of brothers
who were not seamen and and apparently
had been appointed to this voyage
because of through political
appointments they had no way no
understanding of how to conduct
themselves or deal with things such as
this so they convinced the half the
and that Columbus was refusing to go
back to senator Mingo because he was
wanted there and what eventually begin
to happen was the conflict between the
two but primarily at first the the
mutineers took took their frustrations
out on the Indians and began pillaging
the tonneaus there they commandeered ten
dugout canoes and decided they would
they would paddle to to Haiti or what is
now the Dominican Republic they they got
most as had Mendez got most Latinos to
do the heavy work to do the paddling
well the title is certainly at that time
we're not huge people they were they
were smaller stature a strong but still
these are not heavy heavily built people
and particularly they were not used to
being overworked in the way that
Europeans would work so the the
mutineers made these Tai knows paddle
and paddle and paddle under under a
relentless Sun they had no canopies over
these dugouts and they said the Indians
working hard soon exhausted their water
paddling man needs more water than one
who's sitting in the back watching all
of this and soon the titles began dying
off then they got into rough seas and
the dugouts were too low so to lighten
the load the the Christians began
throwing the tie nose overboard and as
the tie nose would Bob back up and grab
onto the onto the edge of the dugouts
the gunnels of the dugouts to try to
hold on the Spanish would pull out their
swords and chop their hands off so they
managed to keep themselves afloat and
they did return to to hate to Jamaica -
- their paddlers the Latinos well by
then their bloodlust was up big-time
and they proceeded to pillage more and
more of the island the food was getting
hard and harder to come by because the
Tytos realize we can't help these people
anymore
they were not were like enough to attack
and defend themselves apparently but a
strange thing happened and I'm not sure
you can believe this story we have it
from from Columbus's son Ferdinand if
you've if you've read your Mark Twain
and the Connecticut Yankee in King
Arthur's Court or if you've seen the
movie with Bing Crosby
you may remember when he's about to be
executed remember this story and he
happens to have the story he goes back a
man from the 19th century goes back into
the time of King Arthur and he carries
with him his Almanac well 20 may have
gotten the idea for this from this
incident I don't know but Columbus had a
good nautical Almanac and he looked in
there he noticed one night where we're
gonna have lunar eclipse tonight so that
day he brought he brought the tyno
leaders to him and according to
Ferdinand gave them this speech about
how the great white god was was
displeased with these people because
they'd stopped bringing food to them and
if they didn't start bringing food that
day the Great God the great job was
going to turn the the moon into into
blood and there's been a great deal of
scoffing and off went the the tie nose
and that night as the Eclipse started
they came back and said oh please please
great white father we will bring you
food well I have trouble with that story
because I would imagine that people had
seen an eclipse before they knew what an
eclipse was but anyway Ferdinand tells
that that yes Columbus thereby through
his witchcraft so to speak is nautical
almanac save save the expedition they
did get more food about that time ovando
spent sent a spy ship to see how the men
were doing he brought they sent several
haunches of a pig in for them to eat but
he refused to pick anybody up he was
merely checking the captain was checking
to see see if Columbus was alive finding
that he was he returned reported to
ovando it and the man said well it was
given some more time about that time the
mutineers decided to attack their fellow
their fellow Europeans and a war broke
out if you can call it that a skirmish
broke out between the two the tie nose
stood back and watched this for once
they can watch the Europeans try to kill
each other instead of them and I can
imagine I have to say this I can imagine
the delight they must have been taking
watch watching these butchers go after
each other probably taking certain
amount of pleasure with with every slice
of the sword every thrust of a spear
well in 1504 Mendez finally got
permission to to
to send a leaky rescue ship almost a
year to the day and the the men who were
a Columbus put down I should say he put
down the the the mutineers and put the
leaders in Chains the rest of the men he
excused so so everybody got off was
still alive then from Finn died from
disease or warfare almost a year to the
day this rescue leaky rescue ship
arrived and off the men went back to
Senator Mingo Columbus was able to hire
a ship to take he take himself and his
brothers on to Spain when he got back
into Spain on in November 12 years and a
month today that he first set foot in
America so everything that happened in
terms of Columbus in America's occurred
in a span of just just 12 years and
believe me I've condensed things
immensely it just is a incredible the
number of events that went on to his
credit the first thing that he did I'm
winding down now the first thing that he
did was to seek compensation for his men
if you've read a little bit about Lewis
and Clark or maybe watched some of the
Ken Burns PBS series on that you may be
aware that both both Meriwether Lewis
and William Clark when they returned to
st. Louis in 1806 spent a great deal
time trying to get money for the
soldiers from the boys across the street
here in Congress it was hard then this
is it hard now Columbus was relentless
in trying to protect his men and and
what they had coming to him
unfortunately three weeks after he
returned this is a bit of bad Columbian
luck isabelo his great supporter died
Ferdinand was not as a supporter
Ferdinand had brutal sympathy with him
he probably didn't really care for
Columbus so things got much harder for
the next few years Columbus tried to put
put some things together he kept working
of trying to restore various rights and
privileges that the crown had he thought
had promised him he spent a lot of time
dealing with bureaucracy in other words
his health was continually getting worse
primarily from from some form of
arthritis at the same time as a man
named Amerigo Vespucci
who
and the exact nature of what it really
did I think is it is difficult for us to
ascertain today but if we believe the
popular story anyway did a fair amount
of exploring primarily around South
America he did two things that Columbus
did not do the first is he stated he
wrote he or had written he wrote a book
I had written a book
he stated that between Spain and Cathay
China was not one ocean but two oceans
and in between was this giant landmass
he had no idea how big it was but he
knew it was huge and this landmass he
was able to place accurately pretty well
Columbus never did either one of those
things when he died when Columbus died
in 1506 he was 55 years old and he still
believed that he had in fact set foot in
the Indies he wasn't quite sure what it
was we thought probably as close to
Malaysia he believed that he had
accomplished most of what he had set out
to do he had not done that he died
believing he had succeeded but in truth
what he had succeeded is he did set
himself up financially he died a
reasonably wealthy man and he left a
nice estate to his heirs if we judge him
by his own goals we can say this he did
not reach the Indies not the East Indies
he did not find the straight to the
Indian Ocean he did not convert more
than two or three Indians during that
time of course conversions would come
later
he did not see Jerusalem returned to the
hands of the Christians so all those
things he wanted to do initially he
didn't do them although he considered
he'd done pretty well in that regard and
if we take the longer view back 500
years we can see that yes some of those
things did did come about if we judging
by our knowledge things that we could
not expect him to know we can say this
he missed what was to become the most
powerful nation on earth entirely he got
close to the Florida Keys but he never
got there he never was able to set foot
anywhere on continental US he missed
South America other than seen it he
misses setting foot there entirely he
missed the Pacific Ocean entirely he
missed as I said earlier the the real
sources of wealth that would come out of
the world other than gold and silver and
a few other things the real long-term
sort resources those he missed and it
gives a it gives American Indians a
certain amount of satisfaction to think
that that one of the great resources to
come out of this this new world tobacco
is in fact a kind of Indians revenge
considering how many people is killed
and sickened this this is the way that
the Indians have gotten gotten back on
the other hand he did initiate the
so-called Columbian Exchange whereby he
brought some good things to the new
world and the new world sent many good
things to the old somebody else clearly
would have done that had he not had he
not done himself but he in fact was the
man that initiated that I think we can
forgive him for those things that he
failed to do those seem to me very human
elements that perhaps anybody even
somebody as good as Columbus wasn't so
many ways you could miss this is the one
that I have trouble with and I want to
conclude with this and then if you have
some questions I'll have a try at them I
have trouble forgiving him for setting
up an economic system and an ethical
system that would lead to the greatest
genocide the world has ever seen because
of what he started and again we can say
if he hadn't somebody else would have
yes that's true but nevertheless he's
the one had he not started what he did
George Catlin would have not gone into
into the West Catlin could see if you if
you've seen the marvelous exhibit here
Catlin would not have gone out there
with the motivation of trying to
preserve visually this way of life that
he knew then in the 1830s was dying I
want to close with this quotation from
Bishop Ellis Costas I must say here that
yeah I very seldom impressed with what
religious people say people in formal
religious sects and certainly I'm not
I'm not in there in the habit of quoting
Bishop's and quoting them with with some
admiration but I have a great deal of
admiration for for Bartolomeo las Casas
he I think was it was it was a splendid
man and had there been more more friars
as he was more religious people more
people of all ilk from Europe who had
come to these shores with his with his
mind we would have a really very
different society today I think that
that what happened to American Indians
who had been far different what happened
happened to American blacks would have
been far different
I think this issues of genocide and
slavery would radically different and
people who say we can't condemn Columbus
because he was a man of his time I'm
sorry the facts don't support that
people knew at that time that what the
things that many of the things that
Columbus and the other conquistadors
were doing they knew they were wrong and
Bishop was costless got himself in hot
water several times speaking out here's
one thing that he wrote it's a short
paragraph he wrote this about the second
voyage after one of the one of the
skirmishes between between the
Christians the Europeans and the Indians
and I think this is epitomizes the whole
question that that that I hope this book
raises and well give you enough
information so you can decide for
yourself
let's Casas says after one of these
skirmishes this is from the second
voyage the Indians fell into the most
wretched way of living some took refuge
in the mountains while others since the
violence and provocation and injuries on
the part of the Christians never ceased
keep in mind this is a Christian Bishop
saying this the part of Christians never
ceased killed some of the Christians for
special damages and tortures that the
Indians suffered then straight away
against them was taken by the Christians
the vengeance which they called
punishment not only the murders but as
many might be in that village or region
were punished with execution and torture
and to think how far we've not come
about that very thing to punish a whole
village one needn't need only go across
the mall here and into the Museum of the
Holocaust and see in Nazi Germany the
same
thing happening then in Stalinist Russia
entire villages entire settles being
attacked we're going to punish two
people in Vichy France you have an
informer we'll take the whole village
this this is the darkest talk I have
ever given and I apologize to in this
wonderful room with these great great
portraits talking about issues so dark
but that was I must confess my
motivation because they think we as
Americans we don't really know what
happened our history were much more
likely to be condemned to repeating
these things I really would like some
people across the street here over in
that house that's painted white I would
like for someone to read some of these
issues and see but that swords really
don't get the job done pull out one
sword there'll be a million swords
coming right behind it
education that has a chance
we only just take a couple
well if they're a couple of brief
questions I will have a go keep in mind
I'm a Colombian scholar because of where
I live yes
more
historical record Columbus giving orders
of a conquistador nature I'm sorry
Columbus giving orders to duck massacres
genocide and plundering every work is
there a historical record
I think most Casas gives the fullest
record of that yes are you asking that
because you you want good evidence that
that in fact really happened oh I was
just kind of curious about if in the
letters that Assunta grated or others
whether there was direct documentation
of giving orders of doing
well he says some of these things of
course he thought he was conducting
proper action as a military leader but
he some of his adversaries later brought
brought legal charges against him and
there was a large fraction of people who
said he did this and or did not do that
and that's that's so complex I don't
know what what what the truth is there
so I just stayed away from from that yes
Gary Snyder
hours
just like come on
for anything
shower
type two
picking out out here
I I don't know how to answer that it's a
wonderful idea
it the problem with writers is that is
that we're so damn independent that we
have trouble doing concerted action and
I think that that kind of weakness is
like the protest this weekend there were
so many different viewpoints going on on
out there I'm not sure it was very
effective it was it was spread all over
the place and I think writers tend to do
that not because of necessarily
different viewpoints on certain issues
but because we're such lone Souls we're
probably the wrong people to do it other
than through our work through our books
but the certainly conference is that
that happened at time if conferences do
any good at all this Merck is I'm sorry
ginger you work is a suggestion that
Columbus had sailed to the Grand Banks
with the vast for any evidence
I'm sorry still contrarian
we olders have trouble hearing that's
one of the reasons we're not very good
at doing these things there's been some
suggestion that Columbus may had sail to
the Grand Banks with the Basques is
there any evidence to indicate that may
have been true you could hear the
question not that I'm aware of
he talks about Ultima Thule which was
Iceland then and he did sail in the
North Atlantic but but if he went that
far I'm not aware that we have anything
that he wrote that that would confirm
that I think we have to treat that as as
a fable at this point yes yeah yes you
may have come to my microphone
yes crossing Kroy and the era where
Columbus landed is now a national park
all the interpretive material layer says
that there were both Tainos and carob so
I was wondering what source materials
you consulted you're wondering what what
what materials you can solid because I
mean it's not anything we've ever been
really clear about what everyone's sort
of things that they're both tell you
know I
well the my favorite resource for this
is a wonderful soda print huge to volume
work by Samuel Eliot Morrison about
Columbus which focuses almost entirely
in the voyages Morrison was a great
naval historian and he was also a
Bluewater sailor so you get the point of
view of sailor in this book he talks
about a great deal but also a book
called the tie nose by I'm drawing a
blank on there on the author's name the
title is rising to claim that people
greeted Columbus 1992 by Irving rouse
and he's done some other works Rous he's
done some other works about that about
the Caribbean Indians and there's
another one by David stanard sta NN ard
standard called American Holocaust
Columbus and the conquest of the new
world those were the three things for
that element that I use most heavily